now i know it's not a very jolly
exercise but we have got to the
beginning of a new year and we can look
back at the last year at the mortality
consequences of the pandemic see how it
compared to previous years and get a
sense of kind of where we are it's
really important exercise this shows you
uh just the official death toll that we
get each day and what we do is if we can
just add up all of those numbers and put
them into a bar you can see that it gets
to just over 150 000 that's over the
course of the whole pandemic but it's
not the only way of measuring this you
can also look at the number of people
who had covered on their death
certificate that's a higher number 175
000 but not all of those deaths were
directly down to covert perhaps about 10
percent as many as 10 weren't so 175
maybe 157 or so when you adjust for that
then you've got excess deaths now this
doesn't look at cause of death it just
looks at the total number of deaths from
all causes compares it to the last five
years and you get 151 thousand so very
similar to that official covert toll
there are some differences we'll look at
in a second but then if you take that
number in order to get a kind of more
definitive thing because bear in mind
the population is aging each year it's
getting bigger and as that happens well
you need to adjust for that otherwise
you're going to see that go up and up so
if you adjust for that you get a
slightly lower excess death number so
age-adjusted excess deaths 120
000. where do they fall compared with
last year compared with the previous
year well let's take those two ones so
the first one official toll and 120 000
on the far right and just going to split
them up by the different years to see
when this is happening and actually
actually you don't see it here but you
might see it if i just kind of take
those bars and show them next to each
other look the official toll suggests
that last year was almost as bad as 2020
but look over there age-adjusted excess
deaths last year not as bad still bad
though and it's worth just looking back
over the course of recent history to see
just how bad
this shows you the same kind of thing so
changes in the levels of mortality age
adjusted population adjusted again but
looking back over the long period back
last 50 years and you can see look
there's covert 19 over there on the far
right hand side those red bars and
really there's nothing else in this
period that comes close the only other
years where you have increases uh
because look over this period things are
getting better people are living longer
mortality is going down but you did have
severe flu in 2015 not as bad as any of
the last couple of years but nonetheless
a deterioration and then you had flu as
well in 1976 and to take this looking
even further back so same data going all
the way back to 1900. well again this
period sticks out like a sore thumb
doesn't it look you can go back you can
see the hong kong floor of 1968 that's
not quite as bad as either of these two
years 1963 you had a very severe winter
there's colder temperatures in 200 years
slightly higher mortality uh change
deterioration than we've just seen in
the last year but nowhere near as bad as
cover 90 in the first year and you need
to go back to 1940 world war ii the
blitz to find any year which has been as
bad uh as that first uh year of the
pandemic and really you need to go back
to world war one uh the spanish
influenza to find a period where you've
had multiple years of increasing
mortality compared with the previous
period